[Music]
in this topic you will learn about
Amazon Web Services or AWS Amazon uses
decentralized or distributed IT
infrastructure to make several IT
resources available on demand since the
1990s it has invested millions of
dollars in building and managing
large-scale distributed and efficient IT
infrastructure Amazon launched AWS a
cloud computing platform to allow other
organizations to take advantage of this
reliable IT infrastructure there are
many scenarios in which AWS is an
efficient option for running web
applications or organization portals
let's explore a few AWS use cases a
small manufacturing organization can use
its expertise in expanding its business
through quality production while leaving
IT management to AWS a large enterprise
spread across the globe can utilize AWS
to deliver training to its distributed
workforce in architecture consulting
company can use AWS to get high compute
rendering of its construction prototypes
a media company can use AWS to provide
different types of content such as
videos ebooks and audio files to its
worldwide customers based on the concept
of pay-as-you-go AWS provides a suite of
services that customers can use when
required and without any long-term
commitments or upfront expenditure the
platform enables customers to procure
service such as computing programming
models database storage networking and
development platforms in minutes this
allows the customers to enjoy the
benefit of low operational overheads the
distributed IT infrastructure provided
through AWS has evolved with time
through the lessons learned from over 16
years of experience AWS diligently
listens to
customer feedback this enables the AWS
team to efficiently deliver creative
features and services even today
AWS continues to hone its operational
expertise continually to retain lasting
reliability by employing its own
advances and industry best practices
into its cloud infrastructure as a
result the customers tend to benefit
significantly from AWS these benefits
include the following flexibility
cost-effectiveness scalability and
elasticity security flexibility is the
major benefit of using AWS when compared
with the traditional IT infrastructure
this benefit is realized in different
ways first you get more time for core
business tasks through the instant
availability of new features and
services the traditional IT
infrastructure requires a lot of time in
planning designing procuring hiring and
managing resources second you enjoy
effortless hosting of legacy
applications AWS does not require
rewriting legacy applications or
learning new technologies migrating
legacy applications - aw gives the
benefits of advanced computing as well
as efficient storage last you get a
choice in running services and
applications AWS is flexible enough to
run services and applications separately
or together as a platform you can even
choose to run a part of your IT
infrastructure in AWS and the remaining
part in your data centers large
organizations usually prefer this method
of operation
AWS requires no upfront investment
long-term commitment or minimum expense
this is its significant advantage when
compared to the traditional IT
infrastructure owning and operating
one's own infrastructure requires huge
investments in IT hardware power
bandwidth and human resources through
AWS techniques such as auto scaling and
elastic load balancing can automatically
scale resources they scale up the
required resources to fulfill a sudden
demand and Deven scales them down when
the demand Falls without affecting speed
and performance the AWS techniques are
ideal for dealing with unpredictable and
variable loads as a result the
organization enjoys the benefits of
reduced cost and increased user
satisfaction
AWS delivers end-to-end security and
privacy to its customers it's virtual
infrastructure offers optimum
availability while managing full privacy
for customers and isolation of their
operations customers can expect high
physical security and this is due to
Amazon's several years of experience in
designing developing and running
large-scale IT operation centers AWS
ensures confidentiality integrity and
availability of the users data the
purpose of AWS compliance is to enable
you to understand its powerful controls
in action and to maintain security and
data protection AWS provides security to
their global infrastructure along with a
variety of features for securing
critical data in the cloud let's explore
some of the security highlights AWS
sternly controls supervises and audits
physical access to their data centers
and network as a customer you can manage
credentials allowing access to your AWS
account access control list or ACL type
permissions on critical data as well as
encrypted while in storage configure a
virtual private cloud or VPC a virtual
network logically isolated in AWS from
other virtual networks configure and
control the operating system on your own
Amazon Web Services virtual server
configure a security group as a virtual
firewall to keep an eye on the incoming
and outgoing traffic for your virtual
servers in AWS state a key pair at the
time of introducing your virtual server
in AWS this key pair is then used to
encrypt login information the AWS IT
infrastructure is designed and managed
according to the best security practices
certifications and IT security standards
these certifications include service
organization control or SOC 1
SOC - and SOC three federal Information
Security Management Act or fi SMA
Department of Defense or DoD information
assurance certification and
accreditation process or dia c.a.p
federal risk and authorization
management program or said ramp DOD
cloud computing security requirements
guide or srg criminal justice
information services or CJ is National
Institute of Standards and Technology or
NIS T payment card industry or PCI data
security standard DSS level 1
international organization for
standardization or iso9001 and ISO to
seven zero zero one u.s. international
traffic in arms regulations or ITA are
section 508 voluntary product
accessibility template or vpat federal
information processing standard or F IPS
publication one for 0-2 the industry
specific standards for customers to
deploy their solutions include Health
Insurance Portability and Accountability
Act or HIPAA the Family Educational
Rights and Privacy Act or FERPA cloud
security alliance or CSA Motion Picture
Association of America or NPA a
hey once become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simply learn
channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here